Now, comes a better question. Can we graph this parabola? Well, the equation
isn't in vertex form. So, we'll need to do something different. We know the
vertex form has a perfect square in it. So, what if we completed the square for
the x terms, so that way we could get a perfect square? Essentially, we want to
change this equation, so it looks like this vertex form. I can group these x
terms together, and then we can add an amount in order to complete the square.
But, since we don't want to complete the square unless the coefficient of this
x squared term is positive one, let's factor out two from both of these terms.
Now, I haven't completed the square yet but I did factor out a two here and
here. This left me with two times the quantity x squared minus 8x plus 33 on
the end. I'm just leaving a spot here in order to complete the square soon. If
we were to complete the square here, what number would we put here in order to
have a perfect square? Type that number in right here.